live it's going on everybody welcome to
Monday melee yes today we're super
excited to badass [ __ ] Brian
Anderson with us we're playing some
battlefield hardline and talking about
he was in the movie American sniper in a
war vet who uh oh my god it's crazy and
has an awesome show on where the mighty
calm called Brian style with a why not
and I just so you know so uh let's get
into it man let's play some heart hot
war you want to play Hotwire I'm down
how our let's do it ro
so I actually play with my arm off all
right I love it I love it yeah that's
amazing yeah the rules are ready to
trade off every death so you'll probably
get a lot more playing time than me
because I suck at this so just just hit
a and guys you can join us
first of all friend me Blair on Xbox one
and we're gonna play a couple matches
just with a bunch of random people so
hopefully we can get our practice in and
then let Beth know when you guys are
playing battlefield hardline and we'll
add you to the game so we can all play
against each other do you know what I
just downloaded some extra maps I'm
super excited about yeah yeah there we
go there we go yeah finally every time
Maps I only play that one I know I know
I know
this is it's gonna be fun I just played
a weird one with skyscrapers so okay
it's pretty that's why we're gonna get
murdered so many times Hey yeah well you
know what neither am i unfortunately
that's right how's everybody doing
Fleur gets flirting good to see you two
soups two soups we're not gonna play on
PC I'm sorry we're still getting our PC
together good lord
I only have one hand the Xbox controller
that's right yes it makes it easy this
is actually cool you didn't you did an
episode of right side where you showed
how you play I did so break it down for
us right now how do you play with just
one hand
well for the people out there with one
hand with only one hand here's how you
do it it took a realization I'm just
trying to do everything like I used to
yeah I had my process
the can I'm like that hand is not gonna
do what I needed to do right so I
realized we'll take it off and use what
you got yeah and so I really kind of hit
these back buttons the top buttons yep
with my die whoa all right and then I
used the toggle with my stump dude doing
stuff that's crazy all right awesome and
then you know yeah and then right here
now yeah I hope most of the games you
know you try to configure them so that
most of the buttons are on the right
side wait yet Shoei no no I'm pretty
good that's gonna like benefit you don't
play invert do you invert and look oh
thank god yeah oh that's awesome you
know we're like it goes down and up and
up and down all right yeah hit hit B
let's get out of this all right perfect
let's go
what's up everybody hey shady fridge
good to see you Oh - yes in the hill a
copter like except you never know when
they're going down I don't know which by
the way is like five minutes after you
get in every single time all right
that's not like art you can do a
parachute yeah oh I just automatically
already die as soon as I get in a
helicopter I'm like I'm this is gonna
end quickly oh wait so Brian we were
talking about before we started you are
the cover of Esquire yes I was and which
means you got to do an awesome
Esquire photoshoot which for me is
horrifying
we were talking about the fact that it's
I know and we know I've done this is
saying this that I'm on camera right now
but having everyone like look at me and
like tell me to go in different poses
that's not jokey like how did you handle
it what was it like like with at the
time Abreu is really cool
yeah Christopher and Christopher Griffin
Christopher Griffin see Griffes we call
him you know that's the secret and it
was in this banquet hall ballroom thing
at the Hilton in Washington
and this was the first photo shoot I had
ever done in my life that's crazy
I mean I was in the Army I was abroad I
worked for me right now before that yeah
they're not doing photo shoots
exactly I'll be naturally handsome
though look I'm trying to get that kind
of scruff really I've been working on it
a week what is it what is this is it
just growing out or are you like a is
that like I'm wanting to grow up man
what's so cool plus my hair doesn't I
didn't shoot it can we turn down the TV
a little bit yeah
so yeah it was so you show up it that
you show up at this banquet hall in this
hotel Nina's the writer who was
recording everything I had said well man
this photographer and and they're just
like hey what's up they seem like too
you know normal dude yeah look yeah
we're gonna bang this photoshoot out and
I'm just like okay and there's like this
little white paper and and there's this
they have like 300 like square foot room
with like 12 feet you're crying to do a
corner of this Jaya he's just like I you
know try a couple different poses but he
made it funny was yeah
awkward really you know cuz it sounds
it just feels to the imposes he wanted
you to do was he like duty and chip like
I know that's doesn't say like alright
okay I said but he didn't give you some
direction yeah yeah he was kind of
little bit and he was like you know just
do whatever you know feels natural or
comes natural yeah and he was good about
having fun with it and that's cool
did they play like music was her music
play I don't remember
okay I was at a lot of drugs back then
okay Jonica months after I got there
actually was no photo shoot it's all
just there is proof there's a magazine
out there so it really did have right
well the funny thing was when the
magazine came out well actually I didn't
know I was gonna be on the cover it
wasn't supposed to be that Oh crazy just
hey can we do a story on you we wanted
to do a story on a veteran I'm sure sure
two weeks before the issue came out
which was in January of oh seven yeah
they called me up and they're like hey
how you doing I'm like oh I'm good
chillin they're like well this this
article it really turned out pretty
pretty cool I'm like good cuz I didn't
think I was all that interesting right
about yeah they're like yeah whatever
okay we're like but you swore a lot you
said so many cars but no I do swear we
all swear a lot we all swear luck yeah
by the way it's fine I don't good yeah
please got a lot of job these people in
the chatter filthy you look at oh my
they're filthy now but they are
sometimes exactly the core seven six -
sometimes Kony comes on sometimes he
doesn't that's right uh yeah tiny poodle
head who's got a tiny poodle head it
can't be me I got a really you you know
what it's only me but look at how big I
mean I guess I just have a death star
and it's not it's full of bees where is
nothing in here when I go buy hats yeah
I have to buy the kids here I mean you
can save money because they're cheaper
yeah so you you win in the end
yeah exactly it's ridiculous yeah see
they're all okay I don't I can't
encourage they're all filthy dirty dirty
bastards yes you're all filthy yes yes
hello oh behind me bleh
oh there's a tiny poodle head oh you can
only see part of this poodle we got a
play we got a play so continue so you
show up and they were really cool about
like making you comfortable and you
actually said something that was really
cool which was because I was saying it
would make me uncomfortable but you kind
of you were just like as long as you're
yourself people respond to that right
but I didn't know that it's all right
this is when you learn this thing is
that we learn that and it was it was
scary it really was yeah but it was
different and the fact that you do the
photo shoot and then you don't see
anything there's no comments right
however long before this
she comes out that's true yeah there's a
delayed reaction kind of that's you kind
of even forgot about even like you said
I forgot what okay we took hundreds of
photos I wonder which photos leading to
you yeah exactly and all the nude ones
if I know Esquire all the naked ones
what that phone call blew my mind so
they're just like oh yeah we're also
gonna go ahead and just throw you on the
cover I'm just like oh no that's so
chill just one of the biggest magazines
ever don't worry about an institution
you're gonna be on the cover of it well
when they first asked me if I wanted to
do this article with them yeah I've
heard of Esquire but I didn't really
know what they're about right and so I
went online and Scarlett Johansson was
on the cover there we go like you would
ScarJo yeah look I could be in the
magazine with somebody like that on the
cover how cool would that be
yeah oh my god and I'm researching a
little bit and this literally like
Robert DeNiro George yes did it's crazy
yeah and Scarlett Johansen and then and
then me that's insane okay whatever
happens then it comes out and everyone
obviously all your friends everyone is
like crapping themselves because you're
undercover
did you tell people you're gonna be on
the cover it was a while I got my news
oh seven yeah I was just coming home
from Walter Reed I'd been there 13
Monday yeah it was it was pretty crazy
that's awesome my god man and it opened
a lot of doors for me
well I'm sure yeah I was like this
7 8 page spread in this awesome little
of Esquire and like the first page of
this article was just a picture of my
face and I'm looking at them like call
the framing shop
[Laughter]
I'm rolling through Chicago O'Hare okay
and I'm going to baggage claim and I was
passing one of those Hudson new
standards oh yeah and I just kind of
like it caught my eye and I just looked
to my right and like the whole top shelf
was escorting me - that's insane
just looking I'm just like - people were
people like No oh because I guess I
would never expect the person who's on
the cover of Esquire to be next to me
indeed right there all right
and I think a lot of people think yeah
no that's true enough but I just kept
rolling I started laughing oh my god
that's a mate and then and since then
you've been you you were an American
sniper you are on CSI New York yes a
Hawaii five-o which by the way best show
to work on ever did you get to go to why
for this oh yeah dude oh that's so ever
to work out what was that week
what was that seven days so oh my god
seven oh it's a guy a little bit a big
and I only had to work like two three
days and then I was hanging out with you
know I hit a except revived Alex lugan
that's insane what so what did you do
what were you in Hawaii five-o what did
you do
I played a woman veteran there was I
don't even know what I'm doing here just
I I just run towards the letters and
just shoot anybody I see that's all I do
okay we made to go like capture these
vehicles yeah oh yeah that's the whole
point hotwire somebody got them
it's hot I would say it is hard to talk
and play video games it's weird it's
gotten to me I'm the constitution yeah I
know it's too when I'm at home and I
play now I just talk to myself it's
really sad although my neighbors think
I'm kill that guy
nice I don't think I got him I think you
did I think that what's glad you know
what blood the blood splatter was on the
dumpster I'm being shy Jesus Jesus Jesus
I was I told you we trade off a lot yeah
that's cool that's crazy so wait so
Hawaii five-o yeah and so those guys
were all great Scott Caan oh yeah Daniel
they can well you did you were you a fan
of law I'm a huge fan of laws
dude it's a meeting he must have been
off meeting him was really cool oh my
god what are we got he played such a
great character in lost - OH we're
diggin in English and he speaks like
perfect English that's so funny
it always it always kind of freaks me
out when like an actor will come on our
show like I'm trying to think of a good
example uh I mean even like Armie Hammer
was a good guy but like or any you know
what any like Australian person comes on
and then they speak it's just like what
like it doesn't make any sense
right but do you know Alice Eve is she's
not really hot blonde chick who is like
in Star Trek she was in LA yes yeah so
she is English and has a very thick
English accent and it totally weirds me
out like I'm just like oh oh stop doing
that accent but that's her normal voice
that's not so funny yeah I know that cam
is like yeah he's just speaks perfect
English are you guys shooting this guy
no so then I started give me give me the
car trying to serve head good and I want
to serve him before no no I got blown up
you know it's funny yeah I do more
things now that I'm like this
you were just so lazy before it was
grateful
I wonder if it's I wonder if it helps
you because you hadn't done surfing
before she didn't know you don't know
wakeboard and snowboard and you were
like freaking gymnast so it's like you
were at natural or natural athlete
anyway I died yep that's what it is man
that's the game we play quick dad you're
right it's [ __ ] I know yeah yeah it's
up it's dumb it's a whole new thing
so why how did you you which is old like
I want to go surfing no no we were just
I don't know how it got brought up but
we were all just sitting and talking and
and then Scott Caan goes oh dude which
is funny because I'm y5o he doesn't like
the water at all yeah it's awesome and
he's been surfing his whole life he
loves surfing that's crazy dude let's go
surf that one yeah okay let's go surfing
it's cool I just put you on the front of
my boat
I'm like like he's that good damn dude
so we go out yeah boys quite a surfer
Scott Caan man you just stop by his
house and grab some supplies go out and
like no [ __ ] I'm sitting on the front of
Scott's surfboard and we're surfing I'm
just like that's crazy this is so cool I
don't know dude I love with surfing is
one of my favorite say I mean I can't do
it cuz my head's too big
yes I'm too top-heavy so I always fall
over yeah but I'm Kate boogie boarder
you know I don't just say it's a
standing up that gets me you know you
got a pop it's like that's the tough
part that's where I'm blessed I don't
have to stay huh you're so like that's
the thing is like because so when I when
I get up it's always the well the board
slipped out from under me but I always
yeah I always like fall forward cuz I
think I try to like jump up this way and
it's the same thing with like you're
saying wakeboarding like I can't get up
in wakeboarding either because I always
pull myself forward and so then I just
eat well yeah I just water gets forced
into every pore in your body when you
[ __ ] up that way but um but surfing is
the coolest thing because it's the earth
moving you which is kind of Awesome like
that's very zen like thinking about that
why never
really I mean no get in the ocean a
couple times yeah family vacations and
stuff but never tried surfing her
thought I could be one that do that yeah
and then me you know we're in Hawaii
every time and I was traveling with
Lieutenant Dan band because I'm what's
Lieutenant Dan band that's Gary Sinise's
band oh my god that's awesome
great name by the way right yeah he does
what does he believe as the Gary Sinise
foundation okay GSM and I'm one of his
ambassadors oh that's awesome and they
do work with veterans and first
responders and they build homes for
soldiers it's also of all kinds of
things well and how they'll do
fundraisers is they'll do these
Lieutenant Dan band concerts are
incredible there's 13 members in the
band they play for like two and a half
hours straight of just sheet music
that's awesome what are we talking like
what are we talking about what are we
talking about like wonder what are some
what were some jams thrives is to throw
it out there like the variety they'll to
play like Leonard Skynyrd's Sweet Home
Alabama awesome I ate this girl Molly
can say will sing Adele's rolling in the
deep' Jesus way to go Molly that song is
amazing she's bad she's a bad girl
that's awesome
killer voice man Julie and dan Meyers
they're great singers Jeff the same damn
oh yeah I just found it they did it
Fenway which I'm still all right dial it
back for us we all know you love the Red
Sox we just did this concert in Chicago
and we Wow come on over for the troops
and there's like 20,000 30,000 people
like you look back that's insane like
you're like this is a cover band but
they're fantastic amazing
that's pretty cool I'm visiting them
hanging out with the great people and
they all like doing what they do or seem
to like it yeah exactly how they like it
[ __ ] all right so let's go steal deep
I'm trying
yeah for God's sakes we got to get into
at least one car here I'm like I can't
even I can't I've gotten run over by
like four cars I haven't gotten a single
one oh wait I did get on a motorcycle
but I don't think that that doesn't
count because it's only the ones it's
like a bar yeah so no one's ever worked
all right hot-wired evening Hotwire
brutal brutal what you got run over I'm
still going I got this no wait being
being a being a war vet do you know are
you better I almost have to do a better
tactics as he gets killed yeah you like
do you use your if your tactics cut to
sleep if that suit when you're not
afraid to die
real bullets are being shot like I'm
going for it I'm Oliver being like these
missions they all happen so fast
yeah in real life it's rarely that it
moves that fast right no you're you try
not to get killed right exactly you
don't want to get shot at around yeah
the goal is to not get shot at period
right let alone steal some some car and
drive around behind a bush let's go not
like let's run towards the danger right
I mean they're a good point very good
boy are times where it's like it's like
you want to do that but you know and
then that happens really fast yeah I
should have known oh I know I know I
know that's true and then yeah and then
everything has got right mama that's
what I keep getting run over to man
these mofos I'm trying to get in this
car but yeah but then you know like
during an ambush - yeah
[ __ ] you like your training takes over
and it's just like what you probably
don't even saw in your vehicle's right
and you have an objective first so it's
like number one you have to complete
that objective right so even though
you're getting ambushed from over here
which it's not like it happened very
often like once that's crazy twice whoa
that's crazy
we just kind of God blessed me anytime
how are you I'm good thank you for being
here we're playing we're playing pal
Phil how do you want to play yeah sure
have you seen me play video games what
we're doing trust me yeah I will blow
you away with my ineptitude Brian you
will be stunned if I was just saying how
how it was what you were in to ambushes
yeah that's crazy
and they just everything is just crazy
move super fast what was kind of put the
pedal down to metal shooting that
direction and then finish the objective
that's it could you still if you don't
come back with after finishing the
objective they're like we don't care
you're in an ambush like you're right
yeah you didn't do what you had to do
right
I mean crazy you want to go and see if
you you know hit anybody and this is
like the first year like maybe a few
weeks after we align this Jordanian
mission and she's crazy so was just
relaxing for you I mean what is this I
mean it's this experience like to be
doing this you know it doesn't bother
him you know okay okay but we were just
talking about the difference like
because like it's tactics or whatever
right and you don't care about getting
shot really doesn't mean your life no
you act differently my son is playing
some game called destiny and yeah and on
the first level he can respawn all the
time yeah and so he he'll do this stuff
he'll be like dad try this and doesn't
matter if this happens to you cuz you
respawn you're like
I wish we could do that yeah yeah so we
will take the time to go slow and we
lost her we see everything 231 to 0 that
was that was why who are you playing
against we're playing against random
people online ok but if you want to join
us at Blair on Xbox one and we're gonna
we're gonna have a match here in a few
minutes with you guys so yeah but are
all these people on our team - because
they're all suck into them right that's
true it's not just us let's not say
listen that's putting people down yeah
we don't say that that they could stand
to improve yeah that's the way to go
Brian and you - that's how they talk in
the military you could you can probably
improve collected yes right right this
is how I would talk if I was like a
drill sergeant I'd be like I think
there's room for improvement I think we
need to love our inner self little guy
inside of you who needs to be loved and
cared for how do you think that would go
over we'd have troops well after I got
out of basic training I heard at one
point soldiers or recruits were able to
pull out a stress card yes
what and if the drill sergeant was
yelling at you and they were getting too
worked up they can pull out the stress
part in this
Jill starting just had to stop why is it
true I have no idea anybody that's like
the Dutch military really you know yeah
and that is punishment right they have
to put together IKEA so wait how does
what what are you doing now are you just
now you're in a car well explain to me
where we are I don't know where we are
and this is good I don't know exactly
where but what we're supposed to get
these vehicles right and you have to
drive them for a period of time that
helps you score points yeah so well
that's the objective is to be in the car
and all these other guys are trying to
kill you to get you out of the line
right we aren't even managed to steal
one car yet we're not pretty
we were talking about Bram Assad the
cover of Esquire
now awkward it would be for me to do a
photo shoot but you do photo shoots all
the time you have any tips for him on
photo shoot I've mostly done teen
magazine I don't think in every and
every single photo shoot I've ever done
I'm holding puppies I'm making this face
actually you did do one with an owl at
one time which I get at first you could
have disastrous but there they are cool
but you're always aware that any animal
and they only the only tool is you this
afterwards any animal will tear your
face it'll be even even cats and puppies
so I'm afraid they're all they're all
they're all killers at heart did you
enjoy the Esquire photoshoot experience
who's my first one that's a good
roommate Amy Arden but you know what I
mean I yeah that's that's excellent
that's a great place when I was doing
the Crate and Barrel catalog for years
we kind of legitimation you were an
American sniper to you and met Eastwood
yes what was that like crazy I mean
that's insane he's the guy he is he's so
good he's so like there are very few
people I don't and he might be the only
one who has that kind of level of iconic
I've been watching him I mean since the
Spaghetti Westerns all through the
Magnum force and the you know Dirty
Harry movies and then all through his
directing career he's just it's pretty
stunning he's a guy who I'm blown away
by he's on this lot he's probably here
somewhere
busy yeah I'll find him and fight him if
you trust me even at 80 what does he
know like he's like 80 years every
before when we filmed American sniper
Basel I would assume he'd be 85 now yeah
it's he I feel like I like that just
like like has an aura about him you know
like Conan has an aura about him that's
more very odor yeah okay I have an odor
about
it's pretty he's pretty chill normal
yeah long time and yeah yeah and he's
he's quiet soft-spoken guy yeah so I you
know you can almost miss he puts a hat
on and right just kind of keeps to
himself right never realized I think you
could easily you know miss him in the
room that's crazy
yeah because he's yeah it's not he's not
walking around shooting a magnum you
know what's happening now we're driving
this looks a lot like my commute yeah I
try to work tokens including this part
here
yeah I'm trying to where'd you get
points into some games like Forza yeah
you get points if you smashed up with
your car is that true here no only if
you run somebody over which is what I'm
currently looking to do excitable we're
not good at shooting people so I'm just
now trying vehicular homicide is what
I'm going for now come on over here I
just keep trying to this is what I get
distracted by in these games yeah you're
supposed to be it supposed to be a fight
to the death and all I'm thinking about
is where are we I see palm tree so I we
know that where is this Central America
are we Lord or one of the new whoa oh
you got some air there we go is this a
game you play a lot Brian it's yeah it
is what is your favorite game or is we
not allowed to say other no yeah we can
say whatever
okay so whoa my favorite game is second
son what is that infamous infamous it's
it's kind of about
like superheroes villains like its I'm
China yes do not worry it hot word it
what did you do I thought I got one of
the cars I had to capture what you guys
are chuh a Chatty Cathy's no way over
there I'm pulling this team together
those are vehicles that we're supposed
to capture but they have in control
right now so we want to kill them and
take control of that beer that's right
right but I'm also doing my part for the
team finally by capturing one of the
vehicles we drive faster than these get
a drive and you're driving a Prius it
looks like a pretty I think it's some
kind of van situate I don't know I don't
know yeah I think you're actually taking
kids to school I'm over pulling go do it
there we go yes
you gotta get so a nice I gotta get some
in it
I know so how much do you play every day
I know that's good because I think
you'll go insane yeah it's the we were
also saying like there's certain things
like Brian is picked up surfing since
his accident but he never you never
serve her before no yeah so there's like
different picked it up afterwards
yeah okay anything with snowboarding
really yeah no one who's amazing before
able-body
yeah made it halfway down the hill and
started flipping tore everything in my
shoulder oh my god went to Iraq six days
later oh wow Jesus were you just like I
want to see snow before I go to Iraq I'm
from Boston I don't need to see it well
so where do you live now here bourbon
you live in Burbank
okay I'm trying to be nice good no no
yeah he's been on CSI New York Hawaii
five-o which was is the greatest show
ever so we were talking about you got
together for what a week
yeah of that genre boat to shoot to
shoot because you're did you go - you
went to Hawaii and what did you do when
you were there
I went surfing michel teló your first
surfing experience which was with who
well that was just my first surfing
experience with the wife I don't live
with Scott Caan that's correct sir give
me a cool guy he's very cool good yeah
he put me on the front of his board
while he's so he do that for me I doubt
it give much more cachet than I do
oh you went sideways on that but I feel
good I'm running dudes over I think you
sweat guy Josh desserts that you swerve
to avoid him does it go
okay all right and then there's a map of
the general area exactly that looks like
a Club Med map you know when you will
show up the psalm is over here oh wait
hit be hit the other yo yeah they just
hit it all right now that really far oh
oh this is great yeah Bryan plays by
hitting the bumpers with his leg and
then yeah you see his left arm to do the
left stick right what do they do
and it's wait I think you're fine just
just try to get on the bike I hit there
you go
do it trigger right trigger yeah run
them over run him over
you can't run someone one of the cars we
got it yeah yeah
who are you trying to catch we're trying
to get the white we're trying to get the
white letters we're trying to capture
one of those we've already we're doing
okay our team I think is not doing apps
not to eat airplane with motorcycles
doing very well in water yeah that's
enough you just go right exactly
okay I love it well the korsak's say hi
to the chat code if people want to say
hey Chad how except a Hamas's Lula faun
I don't think it's the Bahamas yeah
I haven't seen remem guy in Madras
shorts yeah exactly
who sent us this thank you Brian
Anderson for your service and sacrifice
yeah exactly
so it's master Tony says Conan I'm sure
hitting someone with the bike is
possible I've tried don't do that in
real life man for God's sakes what are
you doing
okay here we go I like this bike the
bike I get road rage too but that's not
a good can you uh oh god what get he's
crazy here I can't even keep up with him
hey what's up bro someone said destiny
said can I apply apply for us internship
that was dust scape 10 Netscape 10
where's my coffee
nice Oh what did you switch to yeah I
just wanted the behind the baby birds to
get nice alright we're doing we're doing
way better helicopters that car yeah we
can get in the helicopter sometimes you
got a Hotwire cruising coin that's a
easy I'm like watch what happened I went
off nowhere on the playing area wait
we're not we're out of the plane here
yeah there's like a certain oh damn it
you want to play you want to try playing
I will be nothing will happen
that's all I know what to do yeah let me
started alright well it's good to take
it'll take a couple seconds so you move
around with this
this is shoot that's basically it that's
I need a is jump yeah yeah or you can
get you wanna get in a car run over
there yeah run over there and right over
there to that car okay there we go that
what to walk now hold the blue button
right Oh blue are there yeah right
trigger right trigger okay there we go
let's go here we go
[Music]
cruising the Bahamas people never
believe me when I say that you act they
think you're faking sometimes in
clueless gamer they know no I'm always
oh yeah oh yeah run into that guy sorry
guys Oh somebody shot a rocket honest
someone shot a rocket but that never
really is a problem for those are guys
right there shooting a rocket at me I
don't know I don't know yeah wait was
that a mistake no no we wanted we were
to get in that I want to get it oh wait
get out of it oh you died
headshot wait no what does that mean
yeah it happened somebody shot you in
the head
oh I always saw was oil tanker no I I
think from the side shot in the head
from this side enemy from behind you fro
from behind no from behind me yeah oh
right exactly people can get behind me I
forgot about that that's why I would not
last
get it Conan Brady Canada for internship
tell Conan where to go you guys so I'm
kind of know it yet and people think
that you're that you know oh yeah wait
but why would I fake being this bad I
don't know nobody knows why would I fake
being this bad nothing in the sky can I
shoot that chopper down let me see it
yeah absolutely
all right I'm just gonna run down the
road for a while there you go
is this a waste of time I mean when we
fought yet you're going somewhere you've
got this jogging yeah gotta get your
cardio wait who's that guy that guy he's
not going to yeah yeah I don't care he's
gonna try to run you over
yeah I just blew something up nice guys
this is really me playing you can do it
Conan all right come here
oh yeah don't read all the comments some
of them are gonna get very very fast
wait a minute exactly I'm shooting at
the ground okay I want to shoot someone
who comes by I'm just gonna wait here
it's coming at you exactly is this is
this good strategy in the real world
probably not
[Laughter]
wait that's our guy that's our friend to
you right yeah
I don't recognize if you're anywhere
near me I don't care if you're on my
cheese or not you're going down you sit
sit what's that thing death dealer oh
yeah you can't shoot that chopper that's
the enemy
that's enemy shoots a shot for shooting
Jesus I was doing fine so you started
jamming out god that was crazy
who uses a chopper as a weapon insane
all right I gotta head back to work this
is about as much excitement as I can
handle real honor to meet you yeah so
cool if you're here in Burbank come by
any time we're here we love to game and
we'll see you soon I hope
say goodbye to folks everybody I'm
taking off I'm gonna go back and figure
out what the state of celebrities on the
show this is much more fun trust me 22
22 years I've been doing that that's
back first of all I'm turning off these
freakin what is that what there yes yeah
and all these messages oh wait you know
we should do let's should we try playing
with fans now I mean all the messages
are people are adding you let's try to
play a fancy how do we get what do I do
is quit see when it comes to that stuff
I'm no good yeah I know this is where
this is where things this is it's all
the menus and stuff that always get his
bug down people are crying
finally finally back this back there we
go exactly
creep away creepers if you're just
joining us were here with Brian Anderson
he's got awesome videos he's got a show
comes out every Tuesday on we are the
mighty dot-com called Brian style where
he's out
killing it let's see wait so do I want
to start this or get out of here first
you have to
the Xbox settings see this is why Xbox
how do we appear at settings yeah she's
gonna if you're a woman online it's very
horrifying and yeah these are settings
no guys we get it thank you
thank you for the notifications
everybody off alright so now we're gonna
go to squad join new squad we're gonna
fight some friends here
all right guys are gonna play with you
here let's see if there are people on
make seat maybe after all this maybe
people aren't even on there doesn't the
green dot mean they're on yeah they have
to be playing battlefield hardline I
think right control and what's playing
see you guys there you go maybe they're
just telling us all to play destiny no
these are our friends yeah yeah these
are friends okay all right sorry yeah no
deal fees would be helpful - oh no DLCs
yeah well that's not that doesn't matter
for this does it i DLCs
all right well forget it you lost your
chance chance jail I don't know
something it goes by so face its word
it's so it's so fast that's right I'm
playing mellow loose yeah that's the one
Oh mellow loser alright let's see oh so
we need to so should we go back to xbox
and then add people yeah to friends
alright let's try it let's try it'll be
worth it if we get even one fan in the
thing cuz we're here for our fans we're
here for our fans
you've got fan here on twitter at
anderson active follow him and also at
we are the mighty here we go friends are
we gonna add these folks 24 respond to
oh boy sorry this is the boring part
alert suggested friends so we do this
message is you think 212 sorry guys
having to keep you up with my messages
apologies I will I am here we go here we
go here we go add to add this person oh
I don't know no one knows no one knows
open profile it's a mystery it's a
mystery add friend great you're you're
the one person we're playing with today
so there you go cuz I mean I can't do
this 212 times for my thing will go
that's fine playing man so tell us what
tell us where you're excited about your
you're an actor you're going you're
you're going on doing acting things is
it weird to go on set but people or is
it fun is it now you kind of got used to
it you've been on a couple shows is they
feel like old hat is it still excite you
like oh it still it's it's still
exciting you're not cheating yeah
they're not jaded but I've never you
know went to school for anything so
everything that I've learned was from
experiences and right so I'm still just
learning and I'm trying to like just
watch everything and see how
everything's done have you thought about
you thought about classes or anything
like but my problem is I can't even
commit a day a week yet that makes it
tough to analyze going on seven jobs
going on and I travel so much
nothing crazy it's like I can't even be
like all right every Monday I'll be here
right right that makes it very difficult
this because it's like I feel like
people a lot of times there's I guess
there's a reason why act like people are
actors also are like waiters cuz it's
like a job you can just drop immediately
right but you have all their more
important stuff you're doing well and
that's one of the cool things about what
I'm doing as far as acting is I don't
I'm not acting to live right have other
jobs and it's yeah it's more of just a
hobby and so I can way less stress
things that I want to do and you know
not be sitting there going after every
audition that comes out and also not
like worrying about paying your rent via
acting like that's the things I always
like how am I gonna make rent this month
oh my god I gotta get this Charmin
commercial or whatever you know like
that that's stressful oh my god that'll
drive you nuts
so I respect them in that for sure oh
absolutely absolutely I mean yeah acting
it's like a whole other thing the thing
too about acting that really gets me is
like like rejection like I feel like
going in you know going into like an
audition where you go in the waiting
room and there's 50 people who all have
gray hair and a brown beard which by the
way that's impossible
so me and Guy Fieri would be all be
going out for the same roles but it's
like you know that that would really get
in my head like and you I think you just
have to and then not getting it and
doing that 200 times and I would really
get to me like yeah you know so you're
right that is kind of about it that's
the cool part about being in your
position where you can actually just do
things and it's all still really fun
guys we gave up on the fan thing I'm
sorry
well I'll add a bunch more people next
time and we'll play but yeah that's
really cool and it's also cool that
you're not jaded about it anymore
so yeah and do you go and speak to
people you're the people to inspire I do
that's pretty cool motivational speaking
public speaking minutes and what's that
like I mean do you school do you have
like a like a mean-ass feel do you have
a speech you kind of give every time you
had a lot of questions and answers how
is that it depends on who's having me
what kind of speech I'm doing so I work
for this wheelchair company called pride
mobility your quantumly had okay
and I create pride mobility or quantum
area yes I do testing and design for
power wheelchairs and whoa that's pretty
cool so I'll go into V A's and do stuff
with them but then you know I've been
working with them so long that different
I don't know I speak at different things
how do we get out oh oh nice
Wow is there a quick exit where's the
car by the way didn't it didn't didn't
even roll by the way you just jumped out
just landed you were like it said this
is right yeah yeah [ __ ] him up this is
by the way a way nicer board this is
like the Bahamas or something we're
touring like the great like Will Smith's
house or something good i funny I went
my friend Pete has this has Escada I'm
from Michigan as this cottage up north
of Michigan and we go there every summer
and what summer mmm bought a house on
the lake on this like little lake like
is that or whatever uh and so we were in
like my friend Pete's boat and I was
like dude like show me a man's house
show get its that's like okay he's like
sure he's like see if you could pick out
which house is eminent and so we're
driving a lot of coasts and like the one
he like grew up like there so it's like
one side of the lake is all like
whatever town is basically but the other
side it's all kind of people who are
rich Wow yeah yeah right yeah it's kind
of like wake file yeah exactly and so
across Lake mile people wrap it in boat
shoes but uh whatsoever driving him like
oh is it that big house he's like no no
no this huge brick you just get get me
laid
what happened just came with the
motorcycle and just water well that's
one way uh you know another like you
know crazy log cabin no it's not that
one then we come upon two houses one
giant white one one like giant black
slate one with like 16 jet skis out
front there was like there's like a a
passageway between the two houses and
there was like a waterfall coming over
the bay and I was like is it that one
he's like that's Emma knows nothing cool
that's great it was crazy man but yeah
so this is Will Smith probably lives in
a giant house like this but I gotta use
the parachute I died yeah I got it
what's the parachute the right bumper
right bumper thing interesting next time
doing the parachute I didn't realize
there was a parachute that's how I
normally just get out of the chopper let
me let me click create' wait we're at
the chopper go all right sweet when
you're testing out like power
wheelchairs and stuff do you get to like
crash them on purpose yes that's awesome
that's crazy I get to destroy
wheelchairs dude that's sick
that's your fault dude stop jumping up
and down it's your comeback kids in that
car how do you get like the rocket
launchers and stuff it's long enough
what is that
just gonna go run to that car
if any battlefield pressure you get a
shout-out it's Google online 87
[Music]
since a senpai that's Beth the lady of
the laptop is best also you know Jason
O'Malley's over here on the soundboard
and he's good-looking too yeah he's just
as cute to you the creeper in the corner
everybody loves bet nobody loves
O'Malley it's how I was hired
oh Jesus I changed my mind
do you feel like like with these video
games we're teaching like a younger
generation to drive terribly it's like
all kids go ahead with video games are
just like I will say oh oh that's bad
really that's you know what I think it
was a faulty car I think was the faulty
wiring and wasn't your fault I mean it
was the trees fault
I'm or that first time I played Grand
Theft Auto I when I first started
playing I remember getting getting into
a cab afterwards and being like I
shouldn't buckle up you know after like
driving for four hours and a cabbage to
running people over like this is really
freaking that's crazy that's well the
motivational speakers gotta be cool it's
gonna be pretty fun at first I didn't
want to be I didn't want to be like the
inspirational guy yeah yeah and then
like when that sweater thing was coming
out or when I was doing the photo shoot
and all that I was at a very weird place
in my life as far as like my mental
status
yeah for sure I'm looking at myself as a
trip lying to you like yeah what the
[ __ ] now what yeah of course man of
course and then it I don't know somehow
I just got in my head you know
very short simple words yeah screw
everybody else it's not about them it's
about me
that's true absolutely so try to figure
out what you can can't do and then try
to make a life you want absolutely and
so I started just trying things and I
got at that same time I got to do an HBO
documentary with James Gandolfini whoa a
live day memories home from Iraq mm-hmm
and sorry I just I'm like you know what
you're just gonna be yourself you're
just gonna put yourself out there
whatever happens happens it doesn't
matter and doesn't matter what I did and
kept getting
dream
[Music]
I'm having a brain fart right that's all
right hand my brain is constantly
farting I think it's something I need to
see a doctor it's just full of good
smelly gas or I need to eat
stop eating less kale we start stop
eating so much kale start eating less
kill but you did say that I started his
shirt what I was doing is right yeah
yeah absolutely so then I just started
taking everything seeing what I could do
with things and where I could go with
something I was having fun with it so
yeah and then the more I had fun the
more opportunities I was getting
absolutely it's like the rules of life
haven't changed it's like stick will
still respond to confidence and people
who are common who they are and what
they want and all those things and
people are having fun with it right it's
like that's the thing it's like I think
that when you see somebody else having
fun with their life you want to also do
that and that doesn't matter who you are
or what's what you've been through you
know right yeah and I saw in an
interview you said yet you wanted it
kind of a depression after all that
happened and then so how did you kind of
what was was there any one event that
kind of pulled you out of it and like
what was that
well after about four months of being
blown up mm-hmm
seeing how many people how many soldiers
you're the squad leader no pressure I
got these there's no Will Smith's house
is getting destroyed right now which is
all this shrubbery take that fresh
crates okay which ones rivers yeah I
think it's the other I think is it the
left trigger those nice nice and the
lights baby let him know you're coming
oh hey Fresh Prince let me in the door
okay I'm gonna make it up these big just
go up the wall yeah there we go this is
exactly how Conan drives
I feel like Conan right now exactly
killed by snow please music be nice he
has kids
yeah I've seen Will Smith's children
that Jaden and who's the other one
willow did she go to the whip my whip my
hair back and forth son oh man oh you
kids with your music you know Jamie no
jada jada yeah what's the lead singer of
having heavy metal band what
when recently well when I saw her it was
in 2004 that's hilarious
yeah it was founded in 2002 what's
wicked wisdom yeah that's it wicked
wisdom they play a white bar outside of
Fort Hood holy crap she was in this
white like I could say yeah yeah I just
she was so buff but dude she's right
back she's rich like crazy and just like
she was married to Will Smith at that
point right yeah yeah that's crazy
Wow oh yeah oh yeah yeah but I just
wonder if that was like before Will
Smith or after Will Smith that's awesome
it was definitely it's crazy here we go
here we go yeah
there's actually a sweet game one of my
favorite games at the time now I think
if I was to go back and play it in the
graphics might suck Oh
tell me I got him Oh tell me I got him -
oh I'll enter the matrix where it's
basically between the second and third
Matrix movies they released this game
which basically you play Jada Pinkett
Smith's character and as like in
parallel with the story so it's like you
remember like in the second Matrix movie
I don't remember there's this there's
this chasing remember they're all going
the opposite way on the on the freeway
and all that stuff so basically you like
get her to the point of in the movie
where Morpheus is but it's kind of cool
so it's like all I give it yeah yeah so
I spent a lot of time like listening to
Jada Pinkett Smith's like voice just
because like that game is so long so
it's really like that's that's what I so
see with her is like that matrix
character which is very odd yeah man
she's ripped she's got some serious guns
that's crazy
it was cool though I was like oh I'm
gonna hit this guy Oh God
did you get him I think so I think yeah
awesome nailed it
we killed him buddy let me get on the
map here we go here we go that's what I
like the fourth guy we've ever killed
man hey we won this time we won
this is our first time we won all right
I think that time for one more game
let's talk about we're talking earlier
about your six-pack and and all that
said what's your workout regimen now
like how do you keep in shape like what
do you do besides like surfing and so or
is it just are you just absolutely so
jealous are you just active like what is
it yeah it's really just not yours
you're a skinny guy you're lucky it's
crazy I gotta like watch what I eat
come on yours as well but this is like
chicken this is all this is no fun this
is no but this is no but maybe but dude
you got awesome tats though what does
that say Live Love thrive whoo that
looks painful
that bad eh how long how long did it
take the hours
oh that's okay yeah it wasn't bad no I
look so okay you happy to see me hop off
on and off the couch real quick yeah
watch your knee room okay do it but so I
do stuff like this every day right I'm
like dude holy crap Susan and I and so
my life yeah I look at like my own
personal jungle gym I used to be a
gymnast you're always a gymnast at heart
so I'm kind of like that's true and so I
make my daily life
sort of like my workout and I do workout
at times yeah but I don't a lot you but
you know yeah cuz you don't need it you
like you know hit the gym and just sweat
in a box cuz you like yeah you just you
run around all day i skateboard I serve
yeah you know I'm traveling a lot going
through airports a lot you know just
pushing a manual chairs pretty good well
yeah that's true man that's crazy yeah I
can't even imagine doing a handstand let
alone being a gymnast seems crazy but
it's not and it's so exciting fun yeah
yeah how did you first like get into
gymnastics like high school well it was
really watching like ninja movies and
stuff yeah flip front flips into action
and stop and I'm just like I want to do
that dammit that's awesome did you ever
take did you ever take any karate or
anything no no but you I mean I'm a
soldier
you're a soldier right so I was just
about to say you can learn self-defense
to this already and they do you like how
to win yeah yeah that's - um and I would
if I fought somebody that knew karate or
anything like that yeah they would think
I had no honor and no respect but they
would be there yeah course I'm gonna
talk to win yeah talk to like exactly
respect you good right exactly
take you down some certain way I'm gonna
that's you know that's what any cuz yeah
that's gonna work you up
yeah war is about that yes I'm gonna hit
you in the nuts
exactly anything and everything I can to
mate manage or make my you're telling me
there's some so tell me about the
eyebrows thing we're talking earlier
don't ask me how we got to this
conversation people without eyebrows and
how that old thing ready in Iraq look
what do you there's salt you're sweating
so much
what's one of the tips that people do so
sweat doesn't get in their eyes okay so
when we are in a racist and crazy that
you almost got him but no so you sweat
so much and the sweats pouring in your
eyes and you gotta it's like a high got
blown up it's routine II it really
somebody said hey oh yeah it hurt I got
blown up it was an ie D actually yeah
yeah it's an idea oh thank you
sufferings fun there we go
but I put chapstick in your eyebrows
that's crazy and that keeps the sweat
from them down into your eyes that's how
I need to do my next workout
chapstick you feel saving the locker
room like wise bleh putting chapstick in
his eye runs that's like crazy
are there any of their tips to beat the
heat because like an LA it routinely cuz
you know where there's no water here and
we're in a coastal town yeah
what about what else is there are there
like the shirt I wear long sleeves like
that's why we wore long sleeves and
pants because really your sweat will get
that wet and then it'll make that way
and then the evaporation process helps
oh my god dude that's sunburn Ennio get
sunburned yeah the iraqis they were
black but it's like a certain type of
black that cool
that's crazy the first six months we
didn't have ice Oh
can somebody just said you yell at the
heat Ally that's what I do it doesn't
make it right get out of here heat comb
heat you're drunk
exactly oh thank you anyway we didn't
have ice for the first while so we had
these bottles of water that we're
drinking it like 130 degrees and just
like ah down you know you know it's
getting in you maybe rehydrate and they
take like little sips right like because
your body will use that or no they do
yes when you're when you're heatstroke
when you're heatstroke take a little sip
otherwise guzzle it as much as possible
well they say guzzling wastes water too
so yeah you're supposed to drink in a
measured pace right whatever that means
whatever that means yeah I wish I could
do that with gin I'm gonna have a lot
less problems I'll tell you that Travis
in the army
yes yeah drink a hot girl fries yep when
there's nothing left the aquafresh tell
people yeah explain how what happened
how you got blown up explain that I know
you I'm talking to you sure you told a
story I don't have let me go away in the
detail ya didn't I didn't get knocked
out or anything yeah not a quick and
easy story but although it is hilarious
what you said to your friends when you
were on your bed so I'll make this story
quick and demands being short we're how
do you do an Iraqi police station I was
driving I both my hands on the bottom of
the steering wheel
my left leg curled up underneath my
right leg my right leg was down driving
and we were making fun of our commander
Captain America and your stories
actually finding a Captain America
American comic book which is kind of
awesome theater of war that's right and
it was Captain America's fault that I
got blown up nah I knew you wasn't any
suction I knew it
satin to me I'm is such a nerd like I
know the Esquire cover super cool but
it's kind of a cooler thing I think
about comic books week yeah
she make you find your commander oh yeah
and I took my hand off the steering
wheel I reached my pocket and grabbed a
smoke because I smoke and as I live
Wednesday light the lighter I saw the
spark from the lighter and the flash
from the explosion at the exact same
time whoa it's that crate like that's
like a movie yes insane that's crazy I
thought I didn't wait no oh yeah the
next thing I saw was smoke fire and a
shower of sparks coming through my door
Jesus and then it was just a pitch-black
and there was one thing cuz I was
knocked out as there's so much smoke
inside the truck whoa be anything in
front of so my first reaction is be like
hey he gets right is right I didn't hear
anything that's crazy it's cuz they had
all jumped out already but it literally
cut my left hand and my legs off
instantly whoa what hang in the floor
boy my hand was in the passenger seat
that's insane
button me sideways in my seat where I
was like laying on my back that's crazy
so you're like they're my legs and then
you're on your back I didn't see it yeah
okay oh I see and I didn't know anything
was really wrong with me yet
I had no right turn so fast yeah I felt
like holy crap I just got my bell rung
like good yeah really good cuz I was
like ringing and vision was weird
it's insane and you like I don't know so
weird but it's also fly's open
it's also crazy that your mom you're
still like your mind is stiff it's crazy
you can even recall on you this is still
amazing a lot of it was my friend is
piecing back giving me pieces back yeah
yeah and then like once they would tell
me things that oh yeah right right right
yeah sorry yeah that's really where a
lot of the memory came back yeah that's
insane Wow and they say you're on your
then you're on your back well they
pulled me out and my first thoughts like
I was still being attacked what's going
on doing something funny hey man what's
up that's one angry bunny
good driver though yeah great driver yes
you're on your back and they're they're
freaking out freaking out and I didn't
really know what was going on and so I
started like assessing myself and I
noticed my fingertip was gone and then
my god that's not so bad and then I go
wipe my face with my left hand and I
just whipped and I'm like oh [ __ ] let's
see my sleeve hang down and just like
that's crazy and then I tried to look
down and my friends forced my head back
down to the ground hoping I wouldn't see
what had happened
right but I saw what happened I'm just
like pull-string swears all the swears
and then I kind of came to this
conclusion like holy that did not just
happen
yeah and then I got this weird feeling
like oh she's hit my mom's gonna kill me
that's great then I looked up my friend
I was gonna be so angry I really felt
like like oh I [ __ ] up
whoa weird you know sure but then I saw
my friends bumble around with the
medical equipment that trying to get
some stuff and freaking out I needed to
like say something and make them yeah I
don't know and I don't know why or how
it came out yeah or even recall thinking
this apparently the first thing I said
was holy [ __ ] you think of you lady yet
I love it
perfect line that is like out of a movie
that's amazing well my friends just
start laughing like God right back on
track yeah yeah okay you know do you
remember saying what you said and I'm
like what do you think I said and he
told me and I'm like [ __ ] yeah and he
goes well thank you made me realize you
were still there that's cool yeah kinda
put him back on track yeah else I'm sure
yeah it's like and it is kind of like
that's why I think comedy is so great
because it can get any message across
and like you know they say that guy
spoonful of sugar makes the medicine go
down and like if you would freaked out
or you'd sit like they would have also
kept freaking out it's but it's like a
good laugh like brings everybody
together just naturally you know that's
crazy
hello yeah there we go
great back scratcher a back scratcher
that's hilarious you used what you got
use what you got man absolutely i that's
great I know that's take mine off okay
without without limbs on exactly that's
true yeah max Creek I bow there's the
legs I saw ask myself that question
every day yeah that's amazing yeah that
is true I mean and we'll think about it
I can reach things on this side yeah but
if I this shoulder itches I'm like oh
that's true yes I can't just scratch my
shoe yeah you're right that's unless you
grab the other arm and do it right and
wouldn't that when I have it on I can I
can reach it right of course yeah oh my
god awesome somebody said do I get
and pains I do every now and again it's
not bad they last 30 seconds to a minute
and what's a fan why don't water oh it's
a fan of pain like I just feel it just
feels like feels like a big ass dude is
stepping on my toes oh my god oh my god
so it's basically when O'Malley gets mad
at me and does that tomorrow I get the
same thing when O'Malley O'Malley has
rage issues sorry for that I heard the
stream I told you to stop drinking man
said that did that it's crazy
uh awesome so we only got 10 more
minutes any more questions for Brian
Anderson hit us up good moment that's
right 10 more Megan hold it I gotta be
yeah oh is that true we get it you want
to end now we can I now if you want no I
love it I love we'll play one more game
one more quick game in the forest we
even play I've never played this level
leader okay
all right awesome also go follow him at
Anderson active on Twitter and we at
we're the mighty and he's got a show
every Tuesday Bryan style at we are the
mighty calm brian stuff i love it i love
it i'm great it plugs great somebody
said i saw how ours I rescued and he
wasn't dead yes yeah there we go the key
and I have n guys with me and two
vehicle or three vehicles total my truck
was the only one that got blown up whoa
so the other guys they call the
helicopter and and you said when you
woke up it was kind of crazy cuz your
mom was there right it literally felt
like three seconds yeah I'm like yeah
and you were like why is my mom in Iraq
that's crazy
passionate car you can click the Stinger
Lowood now
oh yeah did medical marijuana help you
with the pain oh yeah a Purple Heart
that's crazy
among other things
that's just the most well known again
yeah yeah oh yeah your mom was there
when you woke up so you were like I'm
thinking like what idiot brought my mom
mom I told you don't come down around
leave me alone mom
your bears me in front of my friend here
merci mom you're embarrassing me no I'm
not gonna wear the turtleneck dammit I
was pretty much the only one inches in
the story the other guys had shrapnel
wounds and yeah they work technically
injured yeah but it's a scratch yeah
that's funny the guys at Walter Reed
that were missing you know legs above
the knees or more than one limb yeah
we'd look at the guys that were missing
just a leg but below the knee yeah
you're like are you kidding me
that's a [ __ ] scratch don't be
complaining I love people giving each
other [ __ ]
cuz you guys are still super competitive
and like soldiers oh that's great yes
you're still like walk it off that's
crazy
that's the funny but actually the
camaraderie
if Walter Reed was really cool yeah are
a bunch of different injuries then
you're seeing all kinds of things
happening and you know some guys that
would have these really bad traumatic
brain injuries the doctors would
literally cut half their skull out whoa
easy and so that the brain can swell and
for like six months they don't have a
skull piece that's crazy their head
literally goes up and then concave in
and then like you completely Wow their
brain and but they always have to wear
these helmets because if they fall and
something hits them they're yeah you
need that's bad that's yeah you need
your skull you need your that's that's
correct they would even put the skull
pieces I think in their stomach to keep
him alive or so whoa dude senior like I
love sci-fi but like it's be incredible
with like human beings have accomplished
for medicine it's absolutely incredible
that's crazy come on dude Kerber says
you talked about taking classes earlier
but not having enough time to pursue any
studies what would you study if you did
have the time to do so would react actor
absolutely
are you like what do you what's your
what's your position on like method
acting like you know where people are
what happened I will we just bounced off
the ground no oh wait a second
what's your buddy flying yet I don't
know I feel like there's maybe no no
pilot how nice oh there we go oh I think
I think the helicopter helicopter landed
on me what's your position on method
acting like like daily Lois were like
they're in character all day on set like
are you into that or not so into it if
someone came to you and was like I need
you to play Abraham Lincoln alright
would you be then the kind of person who
would want to be in that character all
because they see like he even like ate
lunch like as Abraham Lincoln I don't
know if he was eating so yeah you know
he's eating like a six inch meatball
whatever like as Lincoln but like would
you let see miss intense I seem intense
but I'm not you know your full-time
actor yet right that's true never you
know been in those intense scenes where
you have to like be in your whole world
yeah yeah you know I've done scenes here
and there and I'm working to get there
yeah absolutely
catch of a year from now you've got
we're playing Lincoln in the sequel
linking to a bunch of people I've seen
the tide of saying that your voice
sounds like James Franco's know you do
them very and your look is very James
Franco asked as well I've got that
Franco going on that Franco doe that's
true they're good actors and I never
yeah course spring break to you baby
yeah Spring Break Spring Breakers as
though it was yeah I never saw that
movie
alright spring all I know is they kept
going Spring Break honestly this doesn't
make sense to me because yeah being able
to turn it on and off I mean that's a
good skill yeah
but if you're just in the mindset the
whole time there is no worrying about am
I doing this the right way yeah I don't
know like yet so you stay focused right
of course
like before you go and give a speech to
people uh you know when before you go
and do like a motivate a speaking
engagement do you like how do you get
yourself in that mindset are you eating
it
Oh die die at first yes do you even I
mean do you even get nervous like you've
been in combat like it but it's a
different situation yeah they're
different when I first started giving
speeches I was scared shitless right
with butterflies and I don't looking out
and I've done some pretty big venues
yeah where you know there's it's
generally now at least a couple hundred
damn
I've spoken to 4050 no that's crazy
not to hear my speech but I've just
spoken to 55 it still counts still yes
yeah I mean you're still in probably
crowd on and it's always different but
I've realized that I'm smart enough and
I'm comfortable enough now yeah that I
know that the nervousness is a good
thing right
cuz it makes you try harder yeah no you
know what's out there so bright I don't
get as nervous but I still get you know
butterflies and stuff but yeah I have
fun with it now that's awesome and the
more fun I have with it it seems like
the more people have fun absolutely
I'm jump it out
so how do you hear the parachute jumping
out of ya after nobody knows somebody
answer that for me
Estrada 3:10 yes this is live yep yep
yes everyone just says yes question I
love it I think oh boy wait till this
point all this is over how much more
time we got left in this game
no.13 we're not gonna be able to do 13
it's gonna be crazy
Oh God someone said press a press
oppress a while you do it
and you jump out that's all I want to
hire you really you shot me Arneson all
right my guys at 1:30 I think well I
think we'll we'll cut it there thanks so
much to Brian Anderson for answering
that for me and yeah oh it's all right
now you tell us by the way they have the
the parachute was the first thing we
asked and now it's come full circle we
finally figured it out it's taken us an
hour and a half but thank you guys
thanks to Brian Anderson follow him at
Anderson active and watch his web show
on we are the mighty calm every Tuesday
Brian style and follow we are the mighty
on Twitter thank you guys so much thank
you sir awesome and thank you for
telling us how to finally get the
parachute your breath brought us keep
pace know about like bleh see you guys
next week for money mailer
you